-Thank you so much
for coming on the show.
-Thank you for having me.
I'm on "The Tonight Show."
I'm kind of freaking out.
Hi, Mom.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. This is exciting.
You're joining MSNBC pretty
soon, in the fall.
I mean, we're gonna be
neighbors.
-We are.
-Yeah, congratulations on --
-Do you have any tips for me?
-No. I have none.
For you? No.
You tell me how to do it,
please.
Congrats. Are you excited?
Are you nervous?
Do you know
what you're gonna do?
-I'm so excited.
I mean, there's
so much going on in the world
it turns out, right?
-Yeah.
-Lot of news to talk about.
-Exactly.
-And I'm gonna be joining MSNBC
at a time where there's
a big midterm election,
lot of things to explain
to the American people,
and joining this great team
that's already doing that.
So, I'm excited. I'm thrilled.
I'm ready to get started after I
have a little time to simmer.
-Yeah. When will you start?
Around -- Do we have a date?
September?
Somewhere around there?
-I'm starting in September.
-Great.
-And, again, midterm elections.
Exciting time. Lots going on.
-You know, you just --
you just wrapped up your job
as President Biden's White House
Press Secretary two weeks ago.
-I did.
-I have to say,
you did a fantastic job.
-Thank you.
-Really great job, and that must
be a tough, tough gig.
-It is.
The secret is that it's the best
job I've ever had to date.
And I loved it.
I mean, if I were to wake up --
Sometimes I have these
nightmares --
I don't know
if this happens to you
where you're a surgeon
or you have to do brain surgery
or something like that
and I wake up in a cold sweat.
If I had to do something like
that, I would freak out.
But being at the podium,
explaining difficult things to
the public, that was fun to me.
It was great. I learned
something new every day.
I got to call people up
who were the experts on things.
Jake Sullivan and Brian Deese
and all these people
who knew so much, and I learned
something new every day.
It was fantastic.
-I wanted to get your
perspective on the catastrophic
mass school shooting
that happened yesterday.
Obviously
we're all shaken by this,
but how does the White House
handle events of this type?
-Yeah, I was --
I have two little kids.
I know you have kids
I think that are
a little older than my kids.
-Second and third grade.
Mine are in kindergarten
and preschool.
And the first reaction I had
when I saw the news
was shock, of course,
and I'm sure
this is what they were feeling
in the White House too.
And sadness.
You know, that kind of sadness
that you get
when your throat
feels like it's --
if you talk you're gonna cry,
that kind of sadness.
And then you feel fear.
And I think like so many parents
across the country,
I was thinking about sending my
daughter to kindergarten today
and is she safe,
is she okay there,
what kind of security do they
have, should they have security.
And those
are the kind of thoughts
that are going through your head
when you're in the White House
too,
because you're thinking about
what the country's experiencing,
what communities
are experiencing,
and what you can do
to help heal,
help bring some calm if you can
in that moment.
-Did you hear President Biden's
remarks?
-I did. I did.
Did you watch them last night?
-Yes, I did. Yeah.
-I did, and I think
what people saw who watched
or saw clips later on
was somebody who knows
what it's like to lose a child
and knows what it's like
to have part of your soul
and part of
your heart ripped out,
and that's what he talked about
a little bit last night.
And watching it,
I was thinking --
I was looking at his face
and watching
kind of the crinkles in his eyes
and the emotions,
and I was looking at Dr. Biden
behind him
and thinking these
are people who know that pain.
It doesn't make it heal it
for other people,
but they understand what it is
and it impacts how they live
their lives and how they govern.
-And do you think that is going
to do something finally?
Are people going to -- Is it
change -- Is change coming?
What can people do besides vote
and volunteer?
I mean, what do you think?
It's awful.
-This is a common question
that people ask me,
and I think the most important
thing for people to know is
nobody's powerless in this
moment.
Everybody has a voice.
Everybody can use that voice
in many ways.
Yes, you can vote.
You can also get involved
in a lot of organizations.
There are amazing organizations
fighting for gun reform
out there.
And that's another way
to get involved.
And nobody is powerless.
What I would also say that I
learned from
working in the White House
and working in government
is that you have to
always have hope.
You have to always think that
change is possible
and that maybe it's not gonna
happen next month or next year,
I don't know,
but what happens when you have
tragedies like the one in Texas
is it jerks people awake
in a lot of ways.
I mean, guns are the biggest --
they kill more kids every year
than anything else.
That's a fact.
There are more guns
in this country
than there are people
in this country,
and those type of details
jerk people awake,
and that's sometimes
when change happens.
-Yeah. I appreciate
you giving us your thoughts.
Thank you so much, and good luck
on your new gig over at MSNBC.
-I appreciate it.
-Jen Psaki, everybody.